all right guys bang-bang I have a
special treat for you today
Dustin is here Dustin and I somehow have
become good friends he's one of what 250
Master Sommeliers in the world like it's
less than that actually yeah - 200 -
somewhere around 200 250 that's all
right so between 200 and 250 of him are
running around the world and obviously
he's number one in our hearts thanks for
doing this my pleasure good to be here
for those that know nothing about the
wine world know nothing about you let's
just start with your background kind of
everything before master somali and then
we can get into that process but just
kind of word you grew up and how did you
eventually want to become a Master
Sommelier
yeah so I grew up in Maryland moved
around a lot as a kid I went to four
different elementary schools before we
kind of settled into a place I was you
know going through school I never really
knew what I wanted to do when I went to
college actually was a geography major
because I just liked the topic and I had
no idea what I was going to do when I
was a teenager I started working in
restaurants just to pay bills you know
be able to put gas - my my my tank my
car and things like that pay insurance
started off working at sub shops like
pizza shops you know flipping pizzas and
you know making cheesesteaks and things
like that and when I turned I think it
was 18 or so I went to get a job as a
waiter at TGI Fridays and it was my
first waiter gig and you know was making
a lot more money doing that you like
getting tips so that was great and
stayed there for quite some time
actually ended up bartending and you
know by the time I was doing that from
college and by the time I was graduating
college you know with a geography degree
I was like alright I can I can either go
off and try
do something with my degree and make
about half of what I'm making now or
just like keep doing this this bartender
thing so I stayed doing that for a while
because I just didn't know what I wanted
to do left TGI Fridays bounced around a
couple different restaurants eventually
landed at this restaurant called Ruth's
Chris which is another like chain place
steakhouse down in Baltimore and it was
there that I got exposed to wine so they
didn't have a sommelier on staff but all
the waiters were expected to know a
little bit about wine at a pretty decent
sized wine list a couple hundred
selections she kind of forced to figure
it out and I was in college at the time
and I started learning about it and just
kind of caught the bug really really
quickly it's found to be really
interesting because you know it's this
kind of mysterious product that I didn't
really understand and there's so many
variations of it and comes from four
places in the world the prices were like
so all over the place you could saw a
glass of wine for eight bucks or
something like that at the time or there
was the most expensive bottle I remember
at the epoch back then was twenty five
hundred bucks and I just you know I
remember thinking who in the world would
spend that kind of money and why you
know like why why would why do people
spend money on online Oh get it so I
started reading and just caught it like
really fast and you know found myself in
between classes in school like reading
wine books in my car going to the wine
shop quite a bit and just like you know
walking through and looking at bottles
and buying things for myself
occasionally I just kind of became
obsessed so when I graduated college I
still didn't really know what I wanted
to do I knew I liked wine I was making
money in restaurants and I was also a
big skier so I loved to ski and loved
the mountains so when I graduated I was
like alright I'm just gonna I'm gonna
head to Colorado I'm gonna ski for a
little while keep learning about wine
and and then see what happens that's
exactly what I did so in oh well this oh
five I moved to Colorado - Boulder
and found this gig at a restaurant
called Frasca food and wine where it was
only open for dinner so I could you know
escape and go skiing during the day
closed on Sundays awesome and it had a
Master Sommelier running the the
restaurant it was one of the partners in
the restaurant so it was a great place
to learn about wine so it was awesome it
was like the perfect combination at the
time so I'm learning about wine skiing
loving life everything was great and my
goal when I first moved there was I
wanted to I only want to stay for about
a year or so maybe two years tops and
then the plan was to come back to
Maryland go to grad school I decided I
was gonna get an MBA and go get a you
know real job and and move on with life
but then you know two years kind of came
and went really quickly I was kind of
moving my way through the ranks at this
restaurant and Bobby who is my my boss
and kind of my mentor at the time gave
me give me my first gig as a sommelier
and so here I was you know young guy
like finally working in wine I could see
like a trajectory with it you know I
could see like a career in this and so I
kind of made the decision I'm like you
know what [ __ ] it I'm not going home I'm
staying here I'm gonna keep working on
wine and in order to kind of legitimize
it in my mind this is when I decided to
start pursuing the Quarter Master
Sommeliers diploma as a way to just kind
of validate this decision I'm like well
if I'm going to stay here and kind of
keep working in restaurants and go after
this wine thing I wanted to like feel
like I'm you know doing it the right way
so I started down that path and frankly
like when I first started it I didn't
think I was ever going to go all the way
with it my thought was you know take
like maybe level one level two and kind
of stop there and see what happens but
kind of as it goes you know once you've
kind of completed one level of it you're
kind of inclined to want to keep going
so I get to level three
you know by that point you're like well
[ __ ] it I'm already here I meant like
the finish line I gotta at least try for
the final exam so so what exactly is the
level so you're talking about right
there there's kind of four levels as my
understanding and as I mentioned earlier
there's only about 200 250 people who
get through all four levels so maybe
just talk a little bit about like it is
a Somali a and then how that process
works yeah so you know in the to
generalize sommelier is just a person in
a restaurant who helps you out with your
wine selections normally that person
also is probably running the wine
program in the restaurant so they're you
know building out the wine list they're
making the selections they're the ones
dealing with the distributors and buying
wine it's kind of like a little business
within the business and you know then
they're on the floor at night helping
guests make selections and selling wine
you know I think the the word sommelier
has kind of expanded since when I first
started doing it to mean a lot of
different things like a lot of people in
distribution or people who are teachers
in wine or even like certain people who
work on the production side will call
them so Sommeliers in my night and
there's an argument in the industry
about like what is the sommelier would
exactly that that term mean but in my
mind it's always been a position in a
restaurant where you're helping guests
with with wine selections now the master
sommelier title is a is a distinction
and a credit a credit that's like earned
through going this through this series
of examinations so it's a little bit
different it's not it's a title it's not
a position in a restaurant but the word
some what it is and to earn that title
you go through these different levels so
level one is basically a very
introductory test where you go and for
like two days you're you know you you
take like a wine course and at the end
of the course you take a written exam
and it's like 80 multiple-choice
questions and you the pass where you go
pretty straight for the pass rates
really high
if you know anything about wine going
into it you can probably do pretty well
and people from all different industries
will go take this test just to learn a
little bit more it's really interesting
level to you once you pass that level
one you're allowed to take level two is
more to it there's it gets broken into
three pieces that the service piece
there's a tasting piece and there's a
the theory or kind of like the written
examination part it's definitely harder
you probably need a little bit of
restaurant experience to be able to get
through it you need to have been blind
tasting and like learning how to blind
taste a little bit in order to to get
through it it's still quite basic but
it's definitely much harder than the
first exam so the the rate of the pass
rate goes from caught like 90 or 95% at
level 1 down to about 50% for level 2
but let's say you get through it then
you're entitled to go for level 3 which
is called the advanced exam and the
advanced exam is the same three parts
there's Theory there service there's
tasting but you know again a much higher
level of difficulty there's more to the
blind tasting there's a lot more to the
service exam the level of questioning
for theory is much deeper this is kind
of like really what separates is the
biggest jump is what separates kind of
like the real pros from you know maybe
an enthusiastic consumer for instance
the pass rate for that is usually
somewhere in the vicinity but I caught
20 to 30% most years and then once
you've passed that and a lot you know a
lot of people will take that several
times I took it a couple of times before
I got through once you're through that
then you have to wait to be invited to
take the master's exam so that's level
four and it's basically the exact same
tests as the advanced exam and in the
sense that how it's set up
same number of wines that you blind
tastes the same three sections but again
the level of difficulty of questioning
goes
the intricacy of service that you need
to perform goes up and the wines that
they pour you for the blind tasting get
a little bit more difficult and you have
to score in to pass you have to score at
a higher rate so it's quite difficult
and that the pass rate drops down to
somewhere below 10% some years it's like
3% some years it's five some years it's
a little bit more than that
but if you get a ten percent pass rate
that's pretty that's really strong you
know and a lot of people never get
through I know a lot of people in my
industry who've taken it numerous times
and never get through and the thing is
you can only take it once a year so
there's a lot of people who have been in
the program you know usually by the time
you even get to that level you've put in
years of your life to begin with and
then I know some people have taken the
master's exam a dozen times you know or
close to a dozen times it's just an
enormous amount of your time and energy
that goes into it so it's a it's a very
difficult test so I knew nothing about
wine in general I would literally
embarrass myself if I try to pronounce
99% of wines and I think we were at
dinner once and you or somebody else
brought up this documentary Psalm which
you were featured in and so of course I
went home and Flynn and I watched it and
I was blown away at one the fact that
you subjected yourself to this but to
just learning about how intense it is
right so for those that don't know you
should one definitely go watch the
documentary but two it's it's things
like the blind test right that most
people here that know like oh okay so
what you just closed your eyes and you
taste a wine but it's not just like hey
is this red or white it's literally
where is the wine from what year is it
what type of wine what are the
ingredients like like the level of
understanding and really expertise you
have to have is pretty compelling I mean
it blew my mind so the point where my
favorite part of the documentary is like
somebody's tasting wine and they're
describing it as like a new can of
tennis balls or it tastes like or smells
like cat piss and
and you're kind of like wait a minute
this is such a granular understanding of
wine the different wine regions and
periods of time etc that the study
period like how long did you study to
actually pass that cuz it's not like you
just study for three weeks show up and
like cross your fingers and hope you
pass right no no the so the total amount
of time for me from when I took my
introductory test that first level until
I passed my MS was about five years
which you know there's people who have
passed who have gone through it much
like not much quicker than that but a
little quicker than that it's relatively
fast though there's I would say the
average has got to be somewhere in like
seven to nine year range for I think a
lot of people so it's a significant
amount of time and you know leading up
to the exam I mean you're studying
probably a year out if not like you know
probably call it at least eight months
if you're if you're not studying by six
months out and prepping you're you're
behind it's just an enormous amount of
information to prepare for and you know
the blind tasting piece of it is really
difficult like getting to the point
where you can identify grape varieties
and you know where something's coming
from and you know picking the right
vintages and things like that for the
wines it it sounds like it's one of
these things that you need to be like an
innate taster for but it's not
necessarily that it's just a [ __ ] ton of
practice and really understanding and
doing it over and over and over and over
again so it's a lot so the most
important question I'm gonna ask you is
as you're doing all that practice how
the hell do you not get drunk every
single day right you're just literally
tasting and tasting and tasting and
tasting like how do you not just get
hammered day in and day out for a year
yeah well we spit everything so that's
that's the short answer
you know what does that mean you you
know you put it in your mouth you swish
it around and then you spit it right out
and you can get enough information from
the wine you know your
looking for very specific things you're
looking for like acidity and texture and
tannins and checking for alcohol level
and you know specific things on the
palate that you don't you don't need to
drink it to experience that and to
analyze it so you know you're spending
pretty much everything you taste until
of course you know it's like late at
night you saw on the movie you know when
you're tasting with your buddies
practicing and it's like 2:00 in the
morning last couple of bottles you're
usually consumed so it's about
understanding when to stop spitting and
when to start drinking my one little
story on that and it's it's interesting
just as a person in the industry I've
worked a lot of these big organized
tastings where you know you walk into
like a huge facility and there's like
call it three or four dozen tables with
wineries pouring their wines and things
like that and hundreds of wines being
tasted and whenever it's like an
industry only tasting you know
everybody's really Pro they know what
they're doing they you know they taste
they spit they're taking their notes and
they're out the door and they're usually
a lot of people are usually even working
that night if they're in restaurants you
know they really go these tastings
during the day they do this thing and
they head out to their job and then I've
also worked it when it's you know the
average consumer going to these tastings
and the first 30 45 minutes are
completely normal and then the end of
these things are always the disaster
because everybody has been there like oh
I'm just taking these little sips you
know but it really adds up and it's a
lot it's it's interesting I love it I
love it
once you get through the four levels in
the documentary it's very obvious like
this is a huge moment right because as
you said five seven nine years plenty of
them was actually making fun of me
during it because even though I knew you
passed when you actually got told you
passed I'm running around the room being
like let's go Dustin what do people go
do once they actually are awarded the
title of Master Sommelier like what are
some do they go to a restaurant do they
go somewhere else so what's the kind of
the normal path yeah
say there's any normal path necessarily
I mean I think you know the reason that
a lot of people go through it though is
it does open a lot of doors for you it
opens a world of opportunities because
to earn the distinction is is really
rare right so there's a lot of companies
that are willing to pay for that and
want somebody on their team that has
earned that so your your opportunities
that come your way are really broadened
and a lot of doors get open so but it
can be in all aspects of the industry so
you know I personally when I passed I
wanted to run a really significant wine
program in a restaurant setting because
in my mind you know as like I said that
being sommelier is being in a restaurant
there's an element of service to that so
I went off and became or I should say I
went off and just did it but I got the
opportunity to be the wine director at
Eleven Madison Park here in New York so
I ran that program for about four years
and you know and was crazy time to be a
part of that restaurant when they you
know were being purchased from us HG and
the Danny Meyer group and you know
elevated to three stars Michelin and
making their way up the 50 the top 50
restaurants in the world lists and
things like that was awesome experience
but you know there's a lot of people
that maybe use the earning the MS as a
chance to actually leave restaurants to
go into different aspect of the industry
so that could be importing or
distribution wholesale it could be going
to work for a specific winery like in
California for example like say Napa
Valley you you go to become the kind of
you know global wine ambassador for a
particular brand for instance and travel
the world and so you know that wine or
be a representative of that winery
globally you know there's some people
that that use it to become educators and
it's great for that too so there's a lot
of different ways you can utilize it
there's not necessarily one path I think
it really depends on what you're
passionate about which part of the
industry you're the
interested in and what you really love
to do you know for me for a while it was
restaurants
obviously that's changed since then but
you know there's there's no single you
know one thing that a lot of people do
so you've obviously left kind of that
restaurant scene and you started Verve
wine maybe talk to us a little bit just
like what is that were the current
locations and kind of what are you guys
building under that brand yeah so you
know I spent call it close to 20 years
right in restaurants yeah that's about
right
and I think of like 11 or 12 of those
whereas the sommelier in restaurants you
know culminating with that that job at
the master park my mind you know I
wasn't at the time gonna find it was you
know the best restaurant the best wine
director best sommelier job probably in
the world you don't really get much
better than that
so as like as a song you don't you're
not gonna leave 11s and park and go you
know be a director or sommelier
somewhere else it's just you're at the
top at that point so you know and for me
I always kind of wanted to have my
business I thought for a really long
time that was gonna be restaurant having
you know spent 20 years in restaurants
towards the end of it I kind of realized
you know what it takes to do that and
and I needed a little change of pace so
what I saw actually was an opportunity
to to get into the retail space in a
really interesting way and so when I
left I started Verve and verb is you
know if you break it down and very
simply it's a wine retail business
we've got locations physical locations
here in New York we've got one in
Tribeca we've got a location out in San
Francisco we are later this year opening
a location in Chicago we're super
excited about so it's a growing brand
for me though the the opportunity was
always on the the e-commerce side
because where I saw that was lacking was
you know me as a wine person
person like loves to drink wine and no
knows what I like to drink and you know
has a fairly discerning you know palate
and choice when it comes to drinking
things I know where I like to go to buy
wine in New York City it's not just any
old random place there's only a handful
of places I think do the wine curation
thing really well but what was missing
from that I think was like the
e-commerce side of things they
physically had to kind of go there or
talk to somebody there pick up the phone
or email somebody so to me the the
experience of buying wine was still
pretty still pending backwards you're
just outdated or archaic or whatever you
want to call it so I felt like there was
an opportunity there to to get into the
e-commerce part of wine but have it be
that curation have it be a curious piece
of it way where you know there's the
wines wine calm for instance there's
like Wine Library there's other people
that do the e-commerce thing but they're
doing it on like big brand discount
wines they're you know large like
wineries that you can find and you know
the very big Buddhist you can find them
anywhere
not necessarily they've kind of really
interesting things that I personally
love to drink myself so where I saw the
chance to do something was like okay
let's have the same level of curation
but let's get it online and just make it
easier for people like myself to find
these things on the internet so that's
kind of what we did so we launched in
2016 with the location here in New York
and the e-commerce site Epsilon's grown
that obviously and the goal is I mean in
the long term is to ideally kind of plop
some physical locations and just really
strategic places where it makes it a
little bit easier for us to do the
fulfillment for e-commerce in a
meaningful way and you know basically to
get the kind of cool stuff that I like
to drink and that you know people that
love wine are really into you just make
it easier for consumers and other
markets to get those wines because we're
really spoiled here in New York
like we we get access to things that not
a lot of other markets get access to so
you know wine drinkers that are really
passionate that are really into it in
say middle country somewhere don't get
access to the same sorts of things that
we do here in New York so how do we
build that access and that's something
that like the wine calms and you know
the bigger ecommerce brands aren't doing
it they're only working with brands that
you can find anywhere and everywhere
they're not working with like the really
curate stuff so that's that's kind of
our in a nutshell that's what we're
doing yeah I am we're friends but I will
vouch and say that the whole idea of
ordering this stuff online is a thousand
times easier than walking to a wine
store trying to figure out what I want
where is it
you know do they have it all of those
kind of things we regularly order and
literally get same-day delivery like
it's kind of like an Amazon like
experience of us right but the wines are
brought right to your door and it's this
great thing does it feel to you like the
wine industry in general other than you
named kind of one or two outliers just
technology really hasn't been integrated
into the industry in the way that we've
seen maybe in other retail type
businesses and some of that has to do
with I'll call it like the mystique of
wine like the whole idea of the high
price points and and the stories behind
some of the product and all of that or
is it just literally like there's not
that many people who understand
technology and so they're just doing
what they've always done yeah it's a mix
you know there is a kind of romance to
the kind of traditionalism of good wine
you know when a lot of people talk about
the great wineries of the world you know
they tend to be like small places there
are little farms and you know it's like
families that have owned these small
properties for generations and things
like that there's like a romance behind
kind of these old-school small very
traditional like winery businesses right
so it's not necessarily cool to be
really technology forward in wine
because wine
in itself like the fun stuff anyways
it's very traditional and there's like
this kind of adherence to that so I
think that's that's part of it I think
the other part of it is that you know
the people that tend to get into the
wines that like I like to drink and you
know other professionals or people in
the industry or really enthusiastic wine
drinkers like to drink the people that
start those retail businesses are
typically you know very much all about
the wine and all about the curation
process they're not necessarily tech
people and I you know I'm certainly one
of those people I'm not a tech person
myself but there's like an element of it
it's all about the wine for them and saw
about the the curation it's all about
the one-on-one
you know customer interaction and things
like that and kind of keeping things
small which I totally respect and
there's nothing nothing against that by
any stretch of the imagination but where
I saw the opportunity was like you know
there's a lot of other people out there
like me that just want to like be able
to order stuff and like not have it be a
pain in the ass the you know want to
have that same you know where I know
where to go in New York City to go buy a
bottle in a store like you kind of want
to know where's the cool place to go buy
a bottle online it's the same mentality
and that's that's kind of where we saw a
chance to to be a little bit different
and do something differently for sure
and obviously you guys have over the
last four years built an awesome
business both in New York and you've got
the same person
San Francisco location and then couvade
hits and I remember when first it was
like more of a virus and not yet the
government mandated shutdown and then we
had a conversation when actually the
mandate went in place
hey retail businesses you have to shut
down in New York I think at one point it
was a little bit gray area like alcohol
businesses are they essential or they
not I think you guys ended up shutting
down but thankfully you had the
e-commerce business and so it was kind
of this thing we're like it almost feels
like the virus has
accelerated a lot of trends that were
already underway one of those across all
retail verticals being ecommerce
obviously and you guys were really well
positioned over the last couple of years
to kind of capitalize on the fact that
hey if people can't leave and they've
got to order things through their
computer verba verve is one of the best
ways to do that right yeah exactly yeah
it's been really interesting because
like again kind of thinking about how
people normally think about wine retail
is a lot of people think like Oh where's
the good wine shop in my town or you
know I've got to go find this little
place that has like the cool thing you
know so and that's very much I think a
lot of ways that people still shop for
wine that are into it they like to find
a little place that that's in their town
that they can go to that they trust or
that has an interesting selection or
whatever so when we had this idea to do
e-commerce for the same types of wines
and like kind of make that more of a
national thing it was really hard for us
to get people to buy into that like it
was still very much mentality of like
over just a shop down and Tribeca and
that's it you know like that's it was
really difficult to kind of describe and
get people to buy into like the bigger
vision but then you know to your point
Cohen hits we were having a not a hard
time we're accelerating that that
e-commerce business but it wasn't like
it was taking a lot longer for it to
catch on and then we were kind of hoping
it would but then Kobe hits and it just
like shot it way up and you're right we
were really well positioned for that and
I'm really thankful for it we actually
never did shut down we we changed the
model a little bit or I should say we
changed our operations and how we how we
operate but we never actually fully shut
down I frankly my partner and I were
like when this first came around we
thought were gonna have to close in my
mind I'm like how is selling booze gonna
be and it's a quote unquote essential
business I just didn't see it I'm like
now this this little
jury like who needs to drink you know
booze is basically the last legal drug
you know like there's no way with like
hospitals grocery stores and liquor
stores like I just didn't see it so we
thought we were gonna shut down I'm like
making plans on how we're gonna you know
deal with furlough and employees and how
that's how it's gonna go down and all
that and then it comes out that we were
actually considered essential like we
fell into that so you know we're
obviously really pumped about that and
thankful for it but we also wanted to do
what we could to protect our team and
kind of change the way we did things a
little bit and we realized that having
customers continue to come into the
store wasn't wasn't great so we actually
shut the stores down for public walkins
and things like that and just went fully
ecommerce and it was a kind of a risky
move because we didn't at the time it
was still made up of us you know
percentage of the business but it wasn't
a huge percentage of business but we
kind of leaned all the way into it and
realized that it was it was a really
great thing so the stores have
effectively become small warehouses and
fulfillment centers for all of our
e-commerce orders and for the last
two-and-a-half months or however long
it's been now we've been like a hundred
percent ecommerce company and the growth
of the business has been pretty
significant I can't I can't complain
about at all so it's been really
interesting to see what's happened and
to your point it's it's taken what we
were pushing for for a long time and
just accelerated it really quickly you
know and our biggest concern now is how
long is that gonna last when things do
fully reopen are we gonna continue that
online business unless you have to be
seen but I think we've certainly
acquired a lot of new customers which is
great so you know if we're doing our job
well we've got good products and
continue to give good service you're
really hoping that we can retain a lot
of what we've acquired over this course
of time for sure and right now you guys
ship
solely in the cities the physical
locations are in do you ship nationwide
how does that work no we ship nationwide
not to every single state so you know
alcohol still a pretty you know
regulated product so each state is
different it's a lot of post-prohibition
laws that every state has its own rules
and regulations so it's a real big pain
in the ass
to be honest so we don't ship everywhere
but I think we ship out of the lower 48
I think it's like 40 of those lower 48
so most of it you know we do local
delivery in Manhattan and San Francisco
7x7
and then we shipped to everywhere else
that we can ship to so yeah we
definitely get out beyond we have a lot
of customers in other states too like I
said like you don't if you live in
Nebraska or Kansas or you know Wisconsin
or something you just don't get access
to the same kinds of things that you see
in California or New York so the people
that love wine that are out there they
need a place to buy it and so we ship we
do shift quite amount of wine a good
amount of wine outside of New York and
California got it and then you're
incredibly humble so you won't say this
but I'll say you're my most connected
friend when it comes to the New York
City hospitality restaurant alcohol
scene and I remember at one point you
kind of a couple of weeks into the the
shutdown of a lot of these businesses
basically told me like hey it does not
look good for a lot of these restaurants
it doesn't look very good for most of
the hospitality industry and so maybe
kind of just give an update on like what
does that look like in terms of how some
of these businesses have been affected
how effective have they've been at kind
of if you're a restaurant maybe
transitioning to online type business
and then if you had to put a number on
it like what percentage of let's say
businesses in Manhattan in the
hospitality industry don't come back
kind of after this an unfortunate manner
yeah you know it's it's really hard to
tell you know I think as time continues
to go on and
you know we see things start to come
back to normal particularly here in New
York we'll realize who really had
trouble and who didn't you know I don't
think anybody necessarily wants the
press of like you know we're folding
we're giving in we're done we're you
know waving the white flag so I think
we're probably hearing a lot less in the
media about what's actually going on I
know places like eater which is you know
pretty good resource for a lot of what's
happening in the hospitality restaurant
world they've been trying to keep track
of who's closing for good here in New
York but I'm sure they haven't gotten to
everybody they're just working with like
trying to figure out who the biggest
players and like the most popular
restaurants are that are shutting fully
shutting down but you know restaurants
have it really tough right like because
a they need diners coming through
they've got a lost staff those
restaurant the restaurant business model
is it's a very small margin business
they have a ton of expenses the I think
it's really it's gonna be really hard
for them to bounce back and I think the
longer that this goes on and the longer
that they stay closed and they're
continuing to pay rent they don't have
the huge you know piles of money just
sitting in stores you know to be able to
continue to pay rent almost indefinitely
on their spaces you know they need
diners in their spaces to be able to
continue to operate so there's a there's
a limitation on how long they can last
through this closure you know smarter
businesses that you know I've saved up
some money or have figured out really
creative ways to operate through this
whether it's the meal kits or to go or
you know turning there there's their
restaurants into grocery stores or
trying to sell wine you know there may
be bridging the gap a little bit but you
know for a restaurant to actually
operate and and continue to live they
need to be full they need to they need
diners coming in and they need it before
so even
we do reopen whenever that ends up being
the 50% capacity thing and the six foot
between each table regulations that are
going to be put in place for social
distancing which I think if you talk to
any restaurants or anybody in the
industry they agreed that these are all
good measures in order to keep everybody
safe it makes it really hard for them to
continue to survive because particularly
in New York where rents are really high
it's to be it operating at 50% capacity
is a losing battle
you're losing money you're not making
money at that point are my best guess is
most restaurants in New York needs to be
at least like 65% or maybe 70% capacity
to just to break even so you know I
think it's gonna be really hard and I
think the the situation is pretty dire I
think the larger groups you know the us
HDS of the world or the places that have
multiple restaurants and you know a lot
of good backers or if like it's a small
organization but maybe has good good
capital behind them some good investors
behind them they'll be able to get by
because they have access to that
additional additional funding but the
small a lot of small mom and pops you
know the places that are in our
neighborhoods that we love to go to that
are local to us that don't have big bank
accounts or access to capital they're
even having a really hard time so I mean
my my suggestion is you know patron
those businesses as much you can if you
love them and you want them to get
through this and you know my
girlfriend's gonna give me hell for
saying this but by from if they're doing
stuff to go buy from them directly don't
buy through third party apps like
GrubHub and and seamless and things like
that you know because if you haven't
been paying attention those companies
take fees and you know hurts it's it's
tough with restaurants to buy the she's
already given me [ __ ] here we won't say
we won't say why but there's a specific
reason why she's given yeah no I I guess
my my my whole thing is I don't know
what it's gonna look like I think the
situation really sucks it's gonna be
tough I don't know I've heard some
people say they think 30% of the
restaurants in New York are gonna close
some people say 50% some people were
saying 75
I don't know what the right number is I
think the longer this goes on that
percentage is gonna grow and you know
they're in a really tough spot and and
frankly it's there's a lot of
uncertainty too even if they can open up
into 50 percent capacity you know it's
really tough to understand who wants to
go out to eat in these times right like
I don't know if I want to go out to a
restaurant to be around a bunch of other
random people that I don't know and you
know I think so it's uncertainty there's
uncertainty around demand there's
uncertainty around like you know what
the regulations exactly are going to be
you know how long certain restaurants
are able to survive through this so a
lot of us yet to be seen but you know
they're it's it's a really really tough
situation the dining scene in New York
is going to be changed significantly for
a very long time
yeah the thing that's interesting to me
is it's almost like forcing a restaurant
to only be allowed to be open at 50%
capacity it sound like you're confirming
you're really telling them hey you got
open and run a loss for some period of
time right but but like you either if
you're the restaurant owner you either
say okay I'm not going to open at 50%
even though I could be open at 50% I'm
gonna wait until I can open at some
higher percentage so that while I have
my staff there and customers I'm not
running a loss or hey it's important to
be open you know when things come back
so people you stay top of mind and you
drive foot traffic and you know all
those kind of things it's kind of a hard
decision right there's a kind of no
playbook don't one's done this before
you know some people will look at it and
say okay do I am I losing more money by
staying close or would I lose more money
by opening up there's other risk factors
of opening up to like and I'm saying
this in other states now that have
already reopened and people are going
back to these restaurants what happens
if one of your staff members catches a
little bit and you've got to shut down
for another period of time you know
that's that can be a meal on the coffin
for a lot of these restaurants it's not
cheap to reopen your restaurant you have
to buy a lot of inventory you hire staff
that
chances are if you've changed your menu
change your operations around the Gaul
to accommodate these new times get a
retrain so there's gonna be a few days
at least of you know spending money on
labour where you're not bringing any
money in to go through all of that and
then potentially have to shut down again
is of massive risk right you spend a ton
of money reopen a couple weeks later you
got shut down again for a couple of
weeks a huge hit so you know it's it's
it's a it's a huge risk I think to o
reopen into these times there's no
perfect playbook on it yet I don't think
it's gonna return to normalcy until you
probably have the vaccine in place and
you know everything's kind of cool to be
out and about again any time before is
really tough and that's why you see
people like Danny Meyer making these big
pronouncements that he's not going to
open any of his restaurants until you
know maybe there's a vaccine he doesn't
want to operate under these conditions
yeah it's pretty crazy
Balaji Srinivasan came on and he also
says something that thought was really
interesting which was basically not only
are there all the challenges you
described but you're also then asking
these restaurants to essentially be able
to operate in like bio defense mode
right because they also are fighting the
virus they have to clean tables much
more often they've got to be able to
make sure that their staff isn't sick do
kind of all of these things that they
probably directionally we're already
doing it sounds like but now it's just
on hyperdrive because their specific
health you know you know the last thing
in the world you want is to be in the
press label there's a hot spot for kovin
right or you know what what happens now
is like kind of the restaurant that
maybe people want to go to is the one
that has the best sanitization policies
you know and it tends to be the cleanest
and it's the most on display with that
you gotta think about how you're doing
your marketing your social media like
you gotta tell your customers and your
guests like what is it that you're doing
to make sure that all your preventive
measures are in place but then there's
these additional costs too like PPE for
your staff masks gloves temperature
checks all this stuff that needs to be
put
places a whole nother cost item that
just never took place before if you're
doing it the right way if you're
changing out your mass twice a shift
call it throwing those things away you
know you're buying masks and gloves and
stuff at a huge rate for these you know
fairly large teams of people it's a it's
a cost item that just didn't exist
before this so to open into a new
landscape with all these risks where you
can only operate at 50 percent capacity
there's additional cost items it's it's
like a it's really difficult yeah
another thing that seems to be a new
cost item specifically for wine and
we've talked about it before is just the
tariffs and so maybe kind of help us
understand all of the taxation that's
been going on some of it sounds like
there was threats of it happening some
of it's already been passed and and just
how these additional costs when it comes
to the wine industry changes the
economics for importers exporters and in
various retail type locations yeah so
it's funny because once the tariffs was
like the big topic in the industry for
like two months and then Cove it hit and
you know how tariffs feel like it's a
complete topic in the past but it's
definitely having a significant impact
particularly on French wine because
you're seeing I think it's like a 25
percent though there was - there were
two potential tariffs that were being
put in place I can't remember anymore
which one was which but one was for 25
percent and another one was gonna be for
a hundred percent and I think that was
like the like airbus deal that trump was
pissed off about or something but what
ended up happening I think that one got
pushed off and the 25% tariff on French
wine was still put into place and you
know all these things are a little bit
on lag time you know things are on the
water they take time to get here
but now things are starting to arrive
and you know you're seeing these wines
that are certainly more expensive so how
that ends up happening - what the
effect is on the consumer I think kind
of depends on what type of consumer you
are so if what I mean by that is if
you're a pretty savvy wine consumer and
you've your very particular about the
types of wines that you buy and the
specific wineries like let's say that
you really love burgundy or Rhone wines
or you know certain certain champagnes
or something like that you're really
specific about the types of wines that
you buy specific wineries you're gonna
search them out and they're gonna be
more expensive than they were in the
past like if you're used to buying them
before now they've got a premium on them
and use a maybe a collector or Y
enthusiast or whoever you've got to make
a decision on is that extra cost worth
it to you or not and we've seen a lot of
that like you know there's certain
Burgundy wines for example that we've
always sold the last few years and you
know you get pushed back from from
collectors they understand the situation
but maybe in the past they would have
taken a couple of cases of something
they might only take one case or six
bottles something like that so you're
seeing a down ship in the quantities for
sure based on that I think on for for
the average consumer that isn't
necessarily paying as close attention or
have like the same same restrictions
with choice and you know really want
specific things you probably aren't
going to notice it all that much because
you know us for like a retailer for
instance you know we need to make sure
that we have certain categories and
price points that we're always hitting
so you know we need a Sauvignon Blanc
from France for instance that comes in
and hits the Shelf at 15 bucks we're
gonna find that wine no matter who's
making it we're to find one we like that
fits the right price that's right
category and put it in that slot now
might be it not be the same wines before
but the others consumer that's coming
through the door might not realize that
it's different and they're not going to
necessarily care so I think it really
depends on where you fall you know in
the in the spectrum of the type of wine
consumer that you are
if you're savvy and you're used to
buying things you're gonna notice it's
just more expensive I don't think that
that kind of normal consumers gonna are
gonna feel it as much yeah so most
people listen to this we're gonna be
that average retail consumer but
everyone is fascinated with the
collectors or kind of the investors in
wine talked a lot on the podcast in the
past about like fine art or the private
art market and to me the wine investing
role seems you know somewhat comparable
it's a different product obviously but
maybe talk a little bit about kind of
your understanding of how that world
works and what's going on there as we've
kind of the world has changed a little
bit yeah it's um you know wine investing
I think is actually a really interesting
kind of alternative asset if you think
about it it's it does pretty well if
you're the type of person that can spend
wisely and then sit on everything and
just not consume you know it's a little
different than art where you're just
putting something up on the wall like
you know you could it would be like if
you could there was some benefit to
taking that piece of art down and like
destroying it
wine is it sits in your cellar for a
certain amount of time and it can really
appreciate value but then you're also
tempted to want to just pop it open and
drink it and that's gone so if you can
buy quite smartly and keep things around
you could actually make a pretty
significant amount of money on wine now
the difference is you need access to it
you need to be able to understand like
what the good things are and what are
but you know it I think it's a really
interesting investment and you can
certainly do well where it still has yet
to be seen how this the tariff situation
is gonna impact that I think for the
really high ends of wine collecting it's
not gonna matter too much because I
think the same wines are gonna be still
in just as much demand everybody's
buying them for the same price anyway
and maybe the acceleration in value is
gonna slow down a little bit because
they're already starting out of the
premium but I still think that over time
those wines are gonna be worth a lot
more and they're you know you can still
do well what's been interesting in the
segment for me is like there's other
people are starting to get into this
game and one company in particular that
I've kind of like talked with you is
finds wine collecting to be a
fascinating you know kind of segment for
investing they're starting to try to
democratize this a little bit because I
think it really has been left up to the
collectors and the people who really
know wine to to make smart decisions
when it comes to this so the average
investor isn't actually going to touch
it even though it is a really good
investment we need the access to need
the relationships you need to know what
you're buying there are companies now
that are starting to put some
algorithmic structure around how to
invest in wines and doing basically all
the trading for you
so to me that's pretty interesting so I
think the industry is is evolving and
changing a little bit up to that ends
but is yet to be seen like how well some
of these things work
yeah so this is might be a really stupid
question but let's say that you are one
of those wine collectors and you're
buying you know you mentioned earlier
$2,500 bottle of wine how do you
actually know whatever is on the label
is actually what's in the bottle so
whether it's the type of wine where it
comes from how old it is like like all
of these things that kind of make up
that story in the kind of romantic
element that drives the price it appears
like how do people actually verify that
stuff yeah I mean sources is a huge part
of it I would imagine it's pretty
similar I don't know much about a thing
that I would imagine is pretty similar
to that where it could potentially be
like a fake or something like that but
the source is hugely important whether
you're buying directly from the winery
itself or you're buying through an
importer or you're buying through you
know retailer like us for instance that
you can
guarantee the provenance and where it's
coming from
that's a massive part of it you know
outside of that when you start getting
into the world of auctions and trading
between collectors or kind of more open
market on wines it gets tricky now there
there are a number of people out there
that do a lot of work into verification
of wines and there are ways to kind of
check for authenticity without
necessarily just popping to wine open
and checking on it but you do run some
risk you know if you watched that movie
sour grapes or you've heard of Rudy
Kinnear on who was kind of the famous
guy who got arrested for a lot of
fraudulent wine sales there's a lot of
fake line out there on the market
and some of it can be very difficult to
tell if it's a fake or not if they've
done a good job so you know unless
you're buying it the best way to know
that what you're getting is the real
deal is to buy an unreleased either from
a trusted retailer or from the winery
directly outside of that you start to
really increase your risk of buying
something there is a risk a percentage
risk of buying something fraudulent yeah
that makes sense one more topic before
we get to the fun stuff there was
recently some massive drama and frankly
just a cheating scandal in the Smalley a
world maybe talk us through just kind of
like what happened and where things
stand now
sure so this was about a year over a
year and a half ago now towards the end
of 2018 I believe he was like September
October 2018 so what happened was at the
master sommelier exam one of the
examining masters sent out an email to a
handful of people and I think it was
people that he was close with who were
taking the test and basically gave them
a couple of the answers to the blind
tastings like said hey you know here's
couple of wines that are in line up for
your blind tasting
and what happened was is that that email
was brought to light after the exam was
over so nobody reported that email
during the exam everybody went took
their test a bunch of people passed that
year it was actually record number of
people passing the exam so it already -
a lot of us were like wow that's a huge
number of people I was like 20% of
something like that
like 20 people or something so it seemed
a little weird but then about a month
later it comes out that this email was
sent out ahead of time and a handful of
candidates received it what they did
with it was was really up in the air
whether they passed it along or not even
whether they use the information or even
if they saw it before they went into
their test but what happened was that
the organization decided to do an
investigation which I later found out
was it wasn't really much of an
investigation it was basically they
Saturday one just decided to instead of
doing an investigation to just yank
everybody's pin everybody's diploma that
passed and tell him to retake the test
and it turned into a huge thing because
a there was obviously the breach which
made it public but then you know the big
question became did they handle this the
correct way you know is it right to just
it you know kind of consider that
everybody may be cheated on this thing
or had had you know access to this
information and maybe used it
incorrectly been cheated so there's a
huge deal in the organization you know
there's there's still a lot of people
myself included who feel it wasn't
necessarily handled properly other
people will argue with me about that
it's it's kind of settled down at this
point but for about a year or so it was
a huge dealing organization and some of
those people have since going back and
retaking the test and passed
some people went back and failed so not
gotten through some people hated how it
was handled and have decided to just
exit the organization all together and
not pursue it anymore so you know I
think it was a big learning for the
organization of how to maybe protect
themselves against this kind of stuff in
the future but also you know if and when
these things happen how to think about
it the next time around yeah pretty
crazy that this all happened especially
after watching the salm documentary and
understanding the pressure involved in
all of this you know you could see again
just people caving right think about it
like you know people put years of their
lives into this thing it's one of the
biggest achievements that are gonna
happen to life you know I remember how I
felt on the day I passed it's like you
just world you know it's crazy you're
like holy [ __ ] I just became one of
these people and you know you're elated
you work for a very long time you put
your blood sweat and tears into into
passing this thing so I can only imagine
what it's like to be called up a month
later and say hey never minds you've got
to come do this again you know you're
devastated so I can I can empathize with
the candidates
I can also empathize to a certain extent
with the the organization to like their
exam was breach they don't really have a
really clear path to figuring out who
got that access to that information and
who didn't what's the fairest way to
deal with it you know their thought was
let's just pull it back from everybody
make them redo it let's just can't like
void that tense because for them you
know the the you know making sure that
that test and when you earn that diploma
that that's that that integrity is
intact is super important and I don't
blame them for that so you know I can
kind of see both sides of the situation
but you know as a crazy thing I mean
it's just it caused a huge rift within
the organization
a lot of people you know
lost some jobs that they have lined up
because the you know they were waiting
for these people to pass the exam some
people got kind of caught up in bad
press because they were you know
happened to be part of this graduating
class there or the the diploma got
yanked from underneath of them when you
know I know a lot of these people
personally and I know that they there's
no way they cheated you know so it's
it's it's tough to understand how to
think about it but hopefully we won't
have to encounter something like that
again and or if we do that we'll be
better prepared next time cuz it was it
was a cluster it was a mess well the
part I think is so interesting too is it
came out that there was cheating and
really the debate it sounds like it's
not around hey was there cheating or was
there not it's what do we do about it
right and so it's kind of like it when
you get in a situation where everyone
agrees it like something bad happened
that shouldn't have happened
right the like response to that I think
there sounds like there's agreement
around like hey there should be a
response
it's just who do you respond to how do
you do it like like that's where all the
nuance really is totally you know and we
looked at it as like okay and let's say
you go you know take take the SATs or
they got cheating at the SAT now too so
you gotta be careful they got you're
taking your bar exam or something like
that and you know somebody finds out
that there's a leak of information about
the bar exam are you gonna just like
take that away from everybody that took
it that time
probably not you're probably gonna dig
way more into it figure out who had
access to the information who didn't and
maybe make them retake it or you know
figure out some sort of punishment if
there needs to be a punishment but to
just kind of void the whole thing for
everybody I think you know that was
where you know personally I didn't agree
with how they handled it but I don't run
the organization so it's not necessarily
my choice that's my stance all I'll say
is maybe you should okay moving on
[Laughter]
so I asked Twitter for all kinds of
questions and as you can imagine I get
everything from the ridiculous obnoxious
ones to super serious so maybe that's
let's play a little game of rapid fire
first question is what's your favorite
wine and why a favorite wine I was if I
have to pick one thing it's gonna be
wines from the northern Rhone region of
France
I love sarong the Syrah grape it's
actually as we're talking that's where
I'm drinking some Syrah right now so I
drink most of and that's that's like the
homeland of Syrah so northern rum and
I'm not super specific on the specific
winery or region or any of that but
Rouen sorrows or my heart set all right
what's the best brand or wine under $20
oh wow I mean there's a ton of things
it's really hard that's a really tough
question it depends on the grape it
depends on the region that you're
looking to drink I mean I guess if I was
gonna drink something for under 20 bucks
and think about best bang for the buck
I might actually drink Beaujolais sorry
for the sirens here Beaujolais is
probably where you could get a lot of
good bang for your buck all right there
is a I think a report that came out that
the human palate can't tell the
difference when you taste different
wines over 20 bucks I saw somebody
tweeting about this I have no clue what
they're talking about but I figured I'd
ask you since you're the expert what how
is the relationship of the human palate
and the ability to taste the difference
between wines and price point related
yeah people love to have this this play
this game I'm glad that I am surfacing
it to play then yeah I do think you know
in my mind anyway as you know being in
this industry now for a long time and
tasting a lot of things I think that
there is a significant increase in
perception of quality between you know
the lower priced wines and call it up to
around 50 bucks or so a bottle may be
either a little bit higher than that
once you get beyond that it gets really
difficult and it no longer becomes a
question of quality anymore but moreso
branding marketing and and oftentimes
rarity you know rarity and kind of the
supply-demand thing has a huge impact on
pricing and why but up to 50 call it 50
bucks there's actually like a
significant increase in quality like
you're actually paying for better wine
making or better fruit you know better
grapes with a better sight call it so
there is there is some some kind of
linear you know value to be had from
from increasing the price there whether
people can tell the difference or not is
is a different thing right like you know
telling quality and then telling whether
you like it or not are two very
different things like there's a lot of
things that I like that are cheap and
things that I like that are expensive
there's a lot of expensive wine out
there that I think is sucks you know so
I think people need to distinguish what
is quality and what is personal
preference first I think before you can
have that argument my feeling my and
what I've always kind of tout it is if
you like it then it's good and just
drink it so then it kind of removes that
whole that whole argument so I know that
you could do a blind tasting if I put
five wines in front of you right now and
literally you're blindfolded you could
tell me with a scary amount of accuracy
the type of wine where it's from the
general year all of those things do you
think that you would be accurate if I
told you to predict the price at selling
for I think I could be pretty accurate
with that is we we actually used to play
that game quite a bit and it used to be
a way that's one of the reasons why
blind tasting is actually fairly
practical when it comes to being a
sommelier or being like in my position
with retail where you're buying wine
on a regular basis you kind of want to
taste things and understand like where's
the quality here and and be able to say
like alright this wines a good deal or
this is way overpriced but if I taste
something and I'm like okay this is
really good and it should roughly be you
know call it 20 30 bucks on the shelf
and then they want to sell it to me for
$50 I'm like no no way this does not
taste like wine on the flip side if I'm
like wow this is really freakin good
this taste this drinks like something
that's maybe 40 50 bucks and they say oh
it's only $18 I'm gonna buy that I think
it's great
so yes well the answer yes I love it and
I by the way I don't doubt you you know
the general consumer probably isn't
gonna do that so I think you know
between 20 and 50 dollars for most
people that aren't training their palate
on a regular basis and drinking wines
all the time and doing this for their
job you know most people are gonna be
pretty happy buying stuff in there like
20-ish dollar range it's like really
good there's a lot of really good wine
at that price yeah what's the most
underrated wine region most underrated
[Music]
man yeah that could be argued maybe I
think that's a really good question I
could have a lot of arguments Natalie
just put this in my head so I'm gonna
roll with it and I'm gonna say Australia
why Australia gets kind of a bad
reputation I would have if this was like
five years ago I would have said
Beaujolais again cuz Beaujolais used to
have a really bad reputation but that's
that reputation has changed and and now
I think everybody knows about it I think
in Australia there's a lot of cool
interesting stuff down there that not a
lot of people know about everybody knows
like yellow tail and big boroughs of
Shiraz and you know the big Cabernets
and like the wines with critters on the
label and things like that
there's actually a ton of other stuff in
Australia that's really interesting and
really good that I think still is kind
of on the upward swing all right what is
the taste difference between biodynamic
wine and regular wine and the caveat
here is I have no clue what the hell
biodynamic wine is so you're gonna have
to explain that
so by Dynamix is just a method of
farming it's kind of like a really
geeked out version of organics like you
know you think of conventional farming
as like you know the goal is to grow
things the most efficiently and have the
least the least amount of interruptions
the most amount of control you're
probably gonna spray a lot of herbicides
pesticides and things and chemicals and
out of your vineyard to get the to get
the to the goal that you're looking to
accomplish organics is very similar to
organics with food right like you're
gonna not spray as many of these
chemicals and things like that or are
you gonna use other control methods
where you know it's kind of less harmful
to the to the vineyard environment
biodynamic is like the really like
hippie nerdy version of that so it it
follows a lot of really interesting and
and weird
philosophies a lot of stuff that follows
like the moon cycle and a lot of these
what they're called preparations where
you put certain things into the soils or
onto the onto the vines themselves at
certain times of the year in order to
follow this and bio dynamics is like
it's it's it definitely creates a very
healthy robust environment for the vines
and for the vineyard like if you see of
biodynamically farms vineyard it just
looks really healthy right if you look
at a conventionally farmed vineyard it
usually is like dirt with vines and some
grapes growing on them and nothing else
whereas it by dynamically farmed
vineyard is like full of life and
grasses and like in
it's flying around all this stuff so you
can tell it's like a very healthy
environment but what it translates to
into the glass is like not really not
really perceivable to - that much of an
extent like you definitely get healthier
fruit coming off the vine so at higher
quality levels you're gonna you know
you're getting better fruit quality here
but you're not necessarily gonna taste a
huge difference between a conventionally
farmed site and a by directly farm site
it's just not it doesn't translate in
the same way
okay what's your favorite at-home line
tool my wine key what is that just the
wine opener the only thing I need I
don't use I don't use [ __ ] here yeah
I've got my my of course Verve branded
my key you know one of these guys just a
little simple double hinge wine key this
all gadgets out there I think 99.9% of
them are all a waste of money
I will tell people that one time at
dinner I opened a bottle of wine in
front of you and I literally thought
that you were gonna like banished me
from the table I was like holy [ __ ] I
have no clue what I'm doing this dudes
open like a million bottles in his life
and I'm over here hoping I don't pop the
the cork and half-assed pull out of the
bottle yeah I think I think if anybody's
like the one kind of gadget if you will
that I think is actually worth the money
is called Corvin cor AVI N and that is I
think it's really only applicable if
what what it does is basically allows
you to access your wines without opening
the cork and you can pour out a single
glass of wine and it's it's a it
preserves the rest of the wine that's
left over the bottle so it's a way that
like if you only like to drink a glass
every now and then and not have to pop
open the bottle it preserves the wine
for a longer period
time so it's really useful only if you
are having like a glass of wine a week
or something
anything beyond that you might as well
just open bottle or if you're a
collector that has a lot of wines in
your cellar and you don't necessarily
want to pop something open or you want
to check in on something to see how it
is Corbin is really useful for that but
otherwise I think most of the things on
the market the aerators and all that
kind of stuff is just cattle I
personally think it's a waste what's the
best movie about wine or the best wine
movie hmm and you can't say Psalm okay I
was gonna be my answer
um you know my favorite side way is
still I like sideways it's a good flick
it's just really funny it's pretty
accurate in and how they just drive why
and they actually did the research and
like talked about it in the right way so
that would be my favorite alright and
now the most important part of our
conversation I've stayed for save for
the end which is you and I both live
with dictators and but one of my
favorite things by the way we're having
this conversation and plenties in the
room with me and Natalie's in the room
with you so they can hear it which makes
it even better that we can have this
conversation but one of my favorite
things that you and I both do is use the
excuse of I'm not done with that yet so
I want you to explain the importance for
every man to know the trick of I'm not
done with that yet as a way to get out
of jail whenever they need it yeah I
think it's a great move and I think it's
uh maybe underutilized I can probably
look around the room right now and find
a few things that I'm not quite done
with yet
meaning my coffee that's sitting on the
counter over here maybe a dish from
lunch that's sitting in the sink
something like that or you know
the coffee table right now is cleaned
off so I can't really use a real-life
example but you know if you've finished
your plate of food and you haven't done
anything with it yet I'm not done with
that I think it's a very solid reason
for why you've left it behind my I
always get [ __ ] you know for you know
I'll take my food over to the sink and
put it in the sink
instead of putting it in the dishwasher
and I always get [ __ ] for that but you
know saying that you maybe want to come
back to it later I think is a very
viable reason to to leave it there it's
really hard to argue with that logic you
you might come back and avacado
where the skin is just like you know
sitting on the counter still but there's
maybe like a smidge a little sliver of
the avocado left you can argue it's not
you're not done pretty reasonable so I
think reasonable what makes this all
funny is does not how like red is polina
with live anger right now because now
Natalie's like losing her mind over here
I think they're actually texting each
other at the moment this is over so
let's get all of our anger out now but
we obviously met each other because
planet and Natalie knew each other and I
always tell people that you Natalie and
then our other friends Holly and kealan
are the only people I know that are in a
group chat where somehow the group chat
is dominated by just photos and text
messages about all the things that you
me and Ollie do that they're not happy
about and so say something dumb it ends
up in the group chat you know leave
something out a photos going in the
group chat I'm like some I'm not ashamed
like I'm perfectly fine because I know
they those two guys do the same thing I
do yeah yeah it's like you got somebody
on your team on the other side of this
it's like yes you know like I got away
with it I know the other guys here are
gonna like support me you know they've
got my back it's know that Dustin wasn't
done with it yet I already know when I
see the photo he wasn't done with it
what do you woody why are you taking
that photo absolutely I have Paulina
send something into the chat I can find
a very reasonable reason for
I you know you did what she did before I
end up asked the same two questions
first is uh what is the most important
book you've ever read the most important
book I've ever read I mean some for my
life well this might be this might
actually be stupid but it had the
biggest impact on my trajectory my
professional career is wine for dummies
that was my first wine book that's an
awesome answer it was the it was the
book that like gave me the introduction
into this this world that I live in now
and it's the book that changed my life
not maybe not the most compelling book
in the world or maybe the most
interesting and certainly not the most
sophisticated but it's had the biggest
impact so I'll say that
do you ever recommend it for other
people to go read it like if people who
are interested in wine today would you
recommend that book well you know when I
read that it was a long time ago so I
don't know I think yeah generally
speaking yes but I also think there are
some other really good introductory
books that are out there for wine
they're probably do a little bit of a
better job at this point alright and the
last question then you get asked me one
to finish up is aliens believer or
non-believer definitely believer why I
believe the universe is just too big
like we have such a small view into
what's out there I just feel like out of
the trillions of other potential planets
there's got to be someone out there
that's like existing right now I just I
don't I think the odds are in our favor
that there is other life at some point
we're we're recording this the day after
it came out that these I'll call them
alien researchers have discovered a
second radio signal so about three or
four
years ago they discovered a radio signal
that was every 16 days was being shot
from you know deep in some other galaxy
you know millions of years away or
whatever the hell it is and so recently
they found a second one that is being
transmitted every 157 days on a bike
perfectly frequent basis and so when I
hear things like that and then they
followed up with we can't explain it it
just furthers my conviction like hey
there's a lot of things we don't
understand and like you find enough of
these radio signals one of them's gonna
be an alien right yeah I mean I don't
know I just think it's there's just it's
too vast that were the for me to think
that we're the only like life-forms out
there I just to me that just doesn't
make logical sense it's just too big
there's too much of a likelihood that
there's other stuff out there so I
believe I think that's gonna end up
being a very very accurate view of the
world what's the one question you have
for me to finish up alright so I asked
you see how he's enlisting help from
Natalie so that later I asked you I will
say where what's the so I asked a
restaurant question I know you're not
necessarily a restaurant person but what
is the when things get back to normal
what is the first restaurant that you
and Polina are gonna want to go to when
you can't I'll give you the the actual
most honest answer possible and then
I'll give you the answer that you're
probably more aiming for the first one
is McDonald's is always going to be a
number one
we've actually gone so I can't really
say that it's gonna be a finger and open
this whole time right like you need to
go from Macau that's what makes them the
best restaurant in the world literally a
pandemic can't shut down McDonald's like
they're always there it's always
consistent you know what you're gonna
get
knows so I think that if I had to choose
one restaurant in me in New York and
obviously this is one that I like that
also pulling alike so kind of the the
overlap of interest five flex muscles
like I feel like flex muscles is uh
probably gonna be the first one other
ones that uh that we like what is ABC
kitchen that's right there we like that
place trying to think of what I like the
Flex muscles yeah so that's great it's
been interesting to ask people because
you know I think it's it's it's kind of
shows what people have been missing
during all of this and I find that I
think a lot of restaurant culture before
kovat happened was everybody will always
wanted to go that new hot restaurant you
know the new opening that like everybody
wants to try to get into you and now
with everything shut down and we can't
go to the places that make us the most
happy and the most comfortable everybody
wants like their standard go-to and like
things that they they miss the most you
know so I think it's it's gonna be
interesting to see what's busy when
things do reopen for sure and it's also
a thing I think where people now
understand that like the restaurant
experience like Restaurant tours have
done this forever it's not just the food
right it's not just the alcohol in the
wine it's also like the social component
of it it's the atmosphere it's the
environment it's the staff it's like all
of these things that feed into like the
actual experience make going to a
restaurant and so when I think of
certain places you know I don't take
around like a New York staple like Union
Square cafe right like when you walk in
there it has a very specific vibe
a very specific type of menu it has very
specific like expectation you have when
you walk in and so I do think that
people will have a greater appreciation
for a lot of that stuff who knows does
that last forever or does it kind of you
know decay over time again but it just
to me like that part's really
interesting because there's some people
who will go to a restaurant specifically
because of the food I think a lot of
people subconsciously they would also go
for those environments to see you
mentioned earlier like what you know it
would be weird to go to Union Square
cafe and be the only person eating in
there mm-hmm right like it actually be
eerie right like you'd kind of like
what's going on here so I do think that
there's almost this like self-fulfilling
prophecy of like as a society or as a
community everyone has to decide to go
back and then once that happens like you
get those environments and like people
want to go more and more and more I just
don't know how long it will take right
no question yeah we'll see we'll see I
think it's gonna be really interesting
to see what what happens when things do
reopen and I think there's gonna be an
element of nostalgia and like
appreciation for the places that like
maybe you took for granted before right
like you really hope don't go away and
you just can't wait to get back to you
and I think at least for a period of
time my guess is it won't be it's not
gonna be the cool thing to try to go the
new hotspot anymore it's gonna be I want
to go support the places that are that
have always been my go-to as my
favorites the places that are most
comfortable with will see for sure where
um for people who want to order wine
where can they go and then people who
want to badger you with questions where
can they find you any internet so Verve
wine calm is where you can order some
awesome wines from us we've got a great
team of people really accessible like
chats and things like that that you can
you know if you're having trouble
finding something or you're just looking
for recommendations and things like that
we try to make it really easy for people
to get those recommendations and talk to
real live humans while you're navigating
the website so that's a great spot I can
be found on Instagram and Twitter at
just
at Dustin Wilson ms on both of those
platforms so those those I check pretty
regularly so what do you use more
Twitter Instagram I'm more of an
Instagram guy I get on Twitter quite a
bit for kind of check news and see
what's going on out there in the world
and what conversations are taking place
but I'm kind of more of a spectator on
Twitter than I am like an engager on
Twitter
same-same yeah not so much I love
watching pomp on Twitter it's great I
gotta remember that you're watching
sometimes it maybe I won't tweet all the
crazy [ __ ] I love it's great I
particularly like outside of John Legend
and Chrissy Teigen as my maybe my
favorite couple on Twitter I think you
and pulling are maybe
edging them out a little bit as my
favorite on Twitter I'm glad that you're
uh
you do of you on there together is
pretty epic I love it I'm glad that
you're buying us back some points after
I said that we live with dictators so
maybe all right listen I appreciate you
taking the time to do this I could not
recommend Verve wine more so go check
that out guys and we'll do this again
Dustin thanks man appreciate it